if you had a day where nobody would
recognize you i don't think i'd be that
different honestly i dropped the whole
trying to be something for somebody a
long time ago so i pretty much walk
through the world except when i want to
be funny or i want to do something
outrageous i don't have any trouble
being myself and i don't have any
trouble saying no when i mean no when uh
i don't feel
there is a you know pressing
uh responsibility to please everyone i'm
not unkind to people i love people i
would much prefer saying hello and who
are you and what are you doing today
then uh giving a selfie because selfies
stop the world you know they stop life
you then go
like that and it's going on instagram uh
to give people a false sense
of relevance people talk about
depression all the time the difference
between depression and sadness sadness
is just
you know from happenstance whatever
happened or didn't happen for you or you
know
grief or whatever it is and depression
is
your body saying
you
i don't want to be this character
anymore
i don't want to hold up this this avatar
that you've created in the world it's
too much for me deep rest your body
needs to be depressed it needs deep rest
from the character that you've been
trying to play i act because i'm broken
in
a lot of pieces
and uh acting gives me a chance to
reconfigure those pieces into a thousand
different things uh that are positive
for people to watch was there a moment
where you first sort of realized like
i want to be a performer this is the
thing that i want to do with my life
uh there was never any other choice from
the time i that there was consciousness
in the body
i was i was looking at a man named percy
my dad who was
the
most incredible character that you'd
ever meet if you met him for five
minutes you thought you knew him for 50
years
and he wrapped everyone that came into
our house in stories and jokes and
i became his calling at a certain point
and he was always super behind me but
from the first time i can remember him
just lighting up the room you know and
him just like wrapping everybody in a
story or whatever and and going oh
that's that's the thing i want to do you
know that's that's what i want to be
my father could have been a great
comedian but he didn't believe that that
was possible for him and so he made a
conservative choice instead he got a
safe job as an accountant and when i was
12 years old
he was let go from that safe job
and our family had to do whatever we
could to survive
i learned many great lessons from my
father
not the least of which was that you can
fail at what you don't want so you might
as well take a chance on doing what you
love you know i watched the effect of my
father's love and humor
and how it altered the world around me
and i thought
that's something to do that's something
worth my time
it wasn't long before i started acting
up you know people would come over to
the house and they'd be greeted by a
seven-year-old throwing himself down a
large flight of stairs
they would say what happened
and i would say i don't know let's check
the replay
i'd go back to the top of the stairs and
come back down in slow motion now fear
is going to be a player in your life
but you get to decide how much
you can spend your whole life imagining
ghosts worrying about the pathway to the
future but all there will ever be
is what's happening here
and the decisions we make in this moment
which are based in either love or fear
so many of us choose our path out of
fear disguised as practicality
what we really want seems impossibly out
of reach and ridiculous to expect so we
never dare to ask the universe for it
when i was about 28 after a decade as a
professional comedian i realized one
night in la that the purpose of my life
had always been to free people from
concern just like my dad
the only one i hadn't freed
was myself
and that's when my search for identity
deepened
i wondered who i'd be without my fame
who would i be if i said things that
people didn't want to hear
or if i defied their expectations of me
and that peace that we're after lies
somewhere beyond personality beyond the
perception of others beyond invention
and disguise even beyond effort itself
you can join the game fight the wars
play with form all you want
but to find real peace you have to let
the armor go your need for acceptance
can make you invisible in this world
don't let anything stand in the way of
the light that shines through this form
risk being seen
in all of your glory
your job is not to figure out how it's
going to happen for you but to open the
door in your head and when the door
opens in real life just walk through it
and don't worry if you miss your queue
because there's always doors opening
they keep opening
and when i say
life doesn't happen to you
it happens for you i really don't know
if that's true
i'm just making a conscious choice to
perceive challenges as something
beneficial so that i can deal with them
in the most productive way
you'll come up with your own style
that's part of the fun
you are ready and able to do beautiful
things in this world
and after you walk through those doors
today you will only ever have two
choices
love or fear
choose love
and don't ever let fear turn you against
your playful heart what's happening
right now inside everybody is they're
going who am i
and they're depressed people go like oh
jim's been depressed and stuff well yeah
i was depressed when i was trying to be
the wizard of oz but now i know that oz
is a character you know i think
everybody deals with that everybody
walks around and they go like why am i
depressed well it's because you're
trying to be something for the world
you know and as soon as you
let that go
better things happen because they're
just happening it's not uh
you know now it's just sadness you know
sadness comes happiness comes it's the
weather that
flies by in the sky it doesn't sit on
you long enough to drown you a few
months ago
i woke up
and
i suddenly got it i understood suddenly
how thought was just an illusory thing
and how
thought is responsible for if not all
most of the suffering
we experience
and then
i suddenly felt like i was looking at
these thoughts from another perspective
and i wondered who is it that's aware
that i'm thinking and suddenly i was
thrown into this expansive
amazing feeling
of freedom
from myself from my problems
you know when i go to sleep at night i'm
not just a guy going to sleep
i'm two-time golden globe winner
jim carrey going
to get some well-needed shut-eye
and when i dream i don't just dream any
old dream
no sir
i dream about being three-time golden
globe winning
actor jim carrey
because then i would be enough
[Applause]
it would finally be true
and i could stop this
this terrible search
for what i know ultimately won't fulfill
me
[Music]
you